Speaker 1: Donald Trump pleaded the fifth
over 400 times yesterday after previously
saying Only guilty people do it. Only the mob
pleads the Fifth. Hillary's staffers are clearly
guilty because they pleaded the Fifth. So let's
back up and talk about what we are seeing here.
Donald Trump yesterday was deposed by New York
Attorney General Letitia James. Donald Trump did
everything he could to avoid having to testify,
to have to be deposed, to give a deposition
in this investigation. This is an investigation
into possible financial crimes by Donald Trump's
business, including over and or undervaluing
assets, depending on what he was trying to
achieve, essentially keeping two sets of books,
something you were not allowed to do. And as CNBC
reports, Trump took the Fifth Amendment more
than 440 times in refusing to answer. New York
Attorney General Letitia James questions. Donald
Trump said he invoked his Fifth Amendment right
to refuse to answer questions by investigators
for New York Attorney General Letitia James.
The scheduled deposition came days after the
FBI raided Mar a Lago, Trump's home as part
of a criminal probe. James is investigating
business practices of the Trump Organization.
Trump's adult children, Donald Trump, Jr.
Eric Trump and Ivanka previously appeared for
depositions in James's probe. As CNN also reports,
Donald Trump declining to answer questions,
stating that, quote, Under the advice of my
counsel and for all of the above reasons, I
declined to answer the questions under the rights
and privileges afforded to every citizen under the
United States Constitution. And yet Donald Trump
had very strong views about the first the Fifth
Amendment in the past. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: The mob takes over.
If you're innocent, why are you taking
the Fifth Amendment? Oh, when you have
your staff. Right. Taking the Fifth Amendment,
taking the Fifth. So they're not prosecuted. When
you have the man that set up the illegal server
taking the Fifth, I think it's disgraceful. Have
you seen what's going on in front of Congress?
Fifth Amendment. Fifth Amendment. Fifth Amendment.
Horrible. Horrible.
Speaker 1: It's like, yeah. Well,
we know that there aren't really any principles.
It's what can I say right now that's convenient
and makes me look good when years ago it was about
this person took the fifth and that person took
the fifth and you wanted to go after them. You
say guilty people take the fifth. The mob takes
the fifth. Innocent people don't do that. Now
Trump takes the Fifth, and his explanation is
that he now gets it. He now understands why people
take the Fifth because he's being railroaded and
it's a witch hunt. And on and on and on and
on. They don't actually have any principles,
whether it's on debt and deficit, whether it's
on government overreach and authoritarianism,
whether it's on business regulation or we're
against regulation. Oh, Twitter doesn't like
anti-vax disinformation. Well, now we want
to regulate Twitter and force Twitter to
have to publish anti-vax disinformation. There
aren't actually any principles. And in a way.
To you and me. This makes the movement seem
pathetic. And it is. It makes the movement
seem corrupt. It makes it seem vapid. And it
is all of those things. But to other people,
it doesn't matter. These right wingers don't care.
They have the same priority as Trump, which is
what can I say today to make me look good?
What can I say today? I try to get out of this
on gas prices. I don't play the games. I don't
play the games of. Oh, well, the president is
a great participant in reducing gas prices when
it's a Democrat. And then I say something else
when it's a Republican, I don't play those games.
But these Republicans, the games is all they have
left, unfortunately, because they have abandoned
policy. And so, as I said earlier in the week,
Herschel Walker, who doesn't want to debate his
opponent, Raphael Warnock, he should just start
saying, Warnock won't debate me. It's completely
made up. But their followers will eat it up and
they will repeat it. And Trump's followers.
I saw some interviews with them outside Mar
a Lago. They're already saying the same thing.
Oh, he's being railroaded. Of course he should
take the Fifth. Oh, but what about all those
times he said, no, no, no, it doesn't matter.
Trump's being railroaded, and that's
the bottom line. So by his own standard,
only guilty people do what he did. Let's now
talk about Trump's reaction to the deposition.